la période estivale s'annonce compliquée
économiquement pensée de ville de 5000
habitants qui en accueille 4500 en plus
chaque année grâce au terme
le thermalisme et un temps de l'activité
de notre cité on estime à 3 4 millions
d'euros tous les commerces tous les
services mais aussi les hébergeurs parce
que il ya de nombreux hébergeurs il ya
plus de 400 hébergeurs sur sur la ville
thermale
donc c'est un impact très important
cette commerçante risquent d'en faire
les frais cela fait 29 ans qu'elle vit
ici
elles redoutent 20 à 30% de moins sur
son chiffre d'affaires
heureusement le travail ont beaucoup
aussi avec les curistes c'est vrai que
toute la saison thermale commence ça se
connaît et quand elle se termine ça se
connaît aussi c'est vraiment un gros
impact
un impact également pour ce restaurateur
installé juste en face des termes il
comptait embaucher un saisonnier mais
risque finalement de se rétracter
la saison va être compliquée sur nos
curistes donc c'est sûr qu'au niveau
personnel je pense qu'on va diminuer on
fera ce qu'on pourra
suivant le monde qu'on aura pour
l'instant on peut penser avoir en fait
comment ça va se passer
un impact enfin sur les emplois
directement liés à l'activité thermale
sur les 62 personnes qui travaillent
habituellement dans l'entreprise la
moitié va se retrouver sans emploi
quant au chômage technique elle va
rentrer chez elle mais elle se rend de
toute façon continuer à être indemnisée
seront indemnisés d'une part par la
société thermale et de prépa en
complément par la direccte
l'heure est maintenant au chiffrage des
dégâts et à bourbon-lancy des travaux
qui pourrait atteindre un million
d'euros et puis surtout à la
reconstruction de ce bâtiment alors
l'année 2019 est totalement arrêté et
puis on espère tous ici que la
réouverture sur un possible dès l'année
prochaine